je vous rappelle le principe non pose
une question si vous répondez bien tout
se passe bien pour vous c'est du vrai
faux et les autres feront le gage
si vous répondez malia que vous avez
fait le gage attention c'est parti on va
démarrer avec on joue pour une henry
corée c'est à dire grand d'une criée
cuillère de ricoré en poudre dans la
bouche et chanter ah qu'elles sont
jolies les filles de mon pays lay lay
lay lay lay c'est valérie bénaïm danser
les bons et à resserrer bon qui va jouer
vrai ou faux mais bon des chercheurs de
l'université de colombie britannique
canada au canada ont prouvé que sans
dormir avec l'odeur de son animal de
compagnie améliorerait le sommeil ça
c'est vrai c'est vrai et bien c'est faux
c'est de s'endormir avec l'odeur de son
partenaire qui améliorerait le sommeil
c'est une vraie étude scientifique qui a
réalisé qui a révélé ça en faisant des
tests grâce à des t-shirts et intérêts
chérèque a toujours des meufs et vous
dise j'ai gardé tout tee shirt pour
dormir ça ça veut dire que la veuve
commences à te kiffe et y'a que des
meufs qui veulent garder des t-shirts
pour dormir alors où les meufs travail
chez fruit of the loom ou chez damart
voilà où je sais pas où mais pas de vent
ou bien est-ce que vous ne rien mais
c'est que toutes les meufs 10 à un
moment je vais garder ton t-shirt pour
dormir
oui je garde mon t-shirt mais tu rentres
chez toi merci à la rochelle mais quelle
lourde est restée la même et ferro moss
et l'éthologie regarder on vous explique
tout ça
vous éprouvez des difficultés pour
trouver le sommeil eh bien nous avons
peut-être trouvé la solution et elle
pourrait être simple comme un tee shirt
c'est une récente étude sur le sommeil
qui a révélé cette découverte une
découverte selon laquelle l'odeur de
notre partenaire nous aiderait à nous
détendre et de fait à trouver le sommeil
marlyse hofer et française chaîne de
l'university of british columbia ont
réalisé plusieurs tests en ce sens pour
tenter d'attester ce phénomène ils ont
placé auprès de plusieurs sujets des
t-shirts imprégné d'une odeur quelconque
pour les uns et pour les autres
imprégnée de l'odeur de leur partenaire
le constat est sans appel tous les
sujets qui se sont endormis avec l'odeur
de la personne qui partage leur vie se
sont endormis plus rapidement et ont eu
un meilleur sommeil
en effet lorsqu'on dort notre organisme
n'est pas en mesure de se défendre
contre les agressions extérieures il
reste donc en alerte jusqu'à ce que des
signes suffisamment important autour de
lui puisque le rassurer sur sa sécurité
un phénomène qui remonteraient à
l'enfance et l'odeur de la maman si vous
n'avez pas de petite amie ne vous jetez
pas sur votre téléphone pour demander à
votre ex un vieux t-shirt salle cette
technique peut fonctionner avec l'odeur
de n'importe quelle personne que vous
aimez les amis votre maman ou un proche
de confiance bref la prochaine fois que
vous aurez du mal à dormir direction le
bac à linge sale 09 les infos on donne
des infos danse et que du coup je sais
que vous qui fait cette émission
eh ben on vous donne des impôts mikkeli
fait tout pour ça que lorsque vous avez
un petit bébé prématuré clean et quand
il est dans sa petite couveuse on lui
met un tee shirt de sa maman pour qu'il
se sente avec elle ou non qui a de
l'amour ont cet esprit on s'entend bien
d'accord battrai mais c'est beau ça
raymond hains petits hôpitaux mais un
casus belli les films on paie les autres
questions des gens non d autres non pas
parce que vous avez perdu c'est d'abord
d'avoir ces chacun surtout alors direct
comme ça quand vous serez producteur
d'émissions où frédéric pour la stampa
des librairies
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça vous plaisait énormément au public et
à les questions du cfr bonjour michel
qu'il est drôle mais c'est pas possible
on me bravo franchement vous êtes énervé
crs nay peur informateurs voilà merci
attention où joue pour une barbe à
tartiner c'est à dire se dessiner une
barbe au nutella
si vous répondez bien vous ne le faites
pas si vous répondez mal bien surtout le
fait manquer si vous répondez bien tous
les autres le feront bien entendu on ne
rate que des bahamas ici c'est lui
encore non isabelle morini bosc est pour
rien bien c'est vous qui le faites c'est
isabelle morini-bosc répond mal non
et isabelle qui le fait tout seul une
barbe au nutella il avait un vrai ou
faux après de nombreuses recherches sur
une photo sexy de jennifer lopez dans
google l'entreprise a décidé de créer
google images vrai ou faux
pas la peine de regarder la réponse
avait pas sur les causes jeu
ah les trois secondes trois de nos faux
eh bien regardez comment google accueil
vaughan image si on pense souvent que
les ingénieurs informatiques sont des
geeks avec des lunettes qui passent
leurs journées devant leur ordinateur
et bien vous allez être étonnés de
connaître le nom de la personne qui a
permis de créer le service google images
cette personne n'est autre que la
chanteuse jennifer lopez
[Musique]
ne nous emballons pas ce n'est pas
l'interprète de let's get loud qui a eu
cette brillante idée de créer un moteur
de recherche par image et qui a quitté
son studio pour aller prendre des cours
d'informatique mais indirectement c'est
grâce à elle que ce service a pu voir le
jour
retour en 2001 alors qu'internet n'en
est qu'au début de son développement
dans le monde et que google n'est pas
encore le géant comprenez aujourd'hui au
même moment j lo elle est au plus haut
de sa carrière et fait le buzz avec une
robe qu'elle porte lors des grammy
awards en 2010 diatement de nombreux
internautes se ruent sur leur ordinateur
et tente de trouver la robe en question
sauf qu'à l'époque google images
n'existe pas encore et les fans de la
chanteuse tombe sur des sites qui ne
contiennent que du texte
face à cette mésaventure eric schmidt le
pdg de google à l'époque explique que
lui et ses équipes ont l'idée de créer
un moteur de recherche qui permettrait
de retrouver directement des images à
partir de mots clés un ciné c'est google
images comme quoi bien choisir sa robe
peut permettre à l'humanité de
progresser des monts d'or
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui sait
vous devez vous faire une barbe d'une
barbe nous ça faisait rien pour moi mais
qui ne vous inquiétez pas vous le faire
mais non ça ça bouffe c'est la rougeole
sont venus la barre lalalala vous êtes
atteint là vous êtes allé aux toilettes
après quelqu'un d'autre voulez-vous on
dirait dartagnan xxi vous fait elle se
fait là-bas est belle et c'est pas mal
de petits bouts et ses mots elle s'est
fait un très joli beaucoup très joli
mais ça vous va hyper bien mais ça vous
va y perdre je vais rester comme ça
toutes les missions
mais voilà elle a menacé quoi rester
comme ça toutes les missions
cyril hanouna oh là là où là c'est la
cousine de castaldi là c'est le
forsonney là qu'il était le roi de l'ace
oui et google images a une utilité qui
est fondamental enfin tout cas chez moi
parce qu'on soit tous ceux des messages
de drague de dana qui se font passer ces
faux défaut des faux comptes de flics
sont assez jolis et qui envoient leurs
photos style en fait moi chaque fois je
copie l'image donc son bureau et après
je la mets sur google images en une
seconde savez si l'image open c'est qu'à
l'image de quelqu'un d'autre qui habite
venir se fait passer pour quelqu'un que
mes deux forces qui leur permet d'offrir
tout de suite si c'est une fausse faute
bien sûr que la position du tout est
sujet de cette experte chez moi je te
fais plein de fois qu'on voit mes photos
je suis seul et ça c'est en fait les
mais faites-le c'est génial mais samar
m6 avec leur avocat jean michel maire
une fois de plus qui donne une info
bravo bas et cette robe de jennifer
lopez spectateurs magnifique qu'en pense
le public a rapporté
mais ces manifs voilà en quoi la portée
parce que là c'est vrai que là
il ya une vraie meuf on va pas se mentir
on dit aux téléspectateurs vous arrivez
vous ou nous à une soirée avec ça même
au lit à oui quand même
et comment il est la commune avec le
confinement dis-moi marisa l'a vécue
confinement quand ça a pété un câble
jennifer lopez
ça passe crème voilà merci moi je
sentais que sa cousine c'est jennifer
lopez mais on va passer à valérie benaïm
bien entendu un plier au maroc et un
pied en algérie on embrasse les
algériens d'ailleurs c'est vrai alors
les chéris on joue pour un show un shot
de tromper couilles à la basse et à
tropicaux mélangés avec du jus de
fenouil d'accord voilà d'accord
attention on joue pour un choc de
tropiques oui quand c'est trop c'est
trop peu oui
valérie bénaïm oui on le doubs une femme
qui faisait un shooting olé olé sur la
plage a reçu une amende de 270 euros
bella aux mains benaouda quoi est ce que
ce serait plus cher que les 135 euros
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi pas ce qui
aurait peut-être attentat à la pudeur
alors us donc je vais dire oui c'est
valérie meriem la femme de loi qui par
là ces femmes de loi là c'est natacha
amal aulas alors les scieries dans le
doubs une femme qui faisait un shooting
olé olé sur la plage a reçu évidemment
de 270 euros c'est faux ah mince c'est
un couple en plein en plein ébat sexuel
qui se fait amender valérie on regarde
et justin va également vous train créé
votre tropicaux ferez partie
ils n'ont pas pu attendre le 11 mai et
ça leur a coûté cher à quelques jours
près seulement cette petite aventure
aurait pu être gratuite mais voilà
visiblement pour ce couple de l'hérault
le confinement avaient déjà trop duré
c'est jeudi dernier en fin d'après midi
que ce couple originaire de la grande
motte a décidé de se rendre sur la plage
pour faire l'amour si la semaine
dernière les plages était encore
interdite en raison du confinement s'est
en plus en pleine journée à la vue de
tous que ces deux amoureux ont cédé à la
tentation de fait les forces de police
n'ont mis que quelques minutes à se
rendre sur place et constater
l'infraction il faut dire que le couple
n'avait vraiment mis aucune chance de
son côté
car en plus de ne pas se cacher les deux
tourtereaux n'avaient même pas rempli
leurs attestations déplacement ne serait
ce qu'au motif d'une petite sortie
sportive autour de leur domicile
les forces de police ont donc décidé de
verbaliser une amende de 135 euros par
personne soit au total 2 170 euros
la prochaine fois ce couple évitera
sûrement de jouer avec la grande motte
en plein jour ouais ouais ouais tu joues
avec la grande motte en plein jour vous
avez eu le sujet est magnifique oui jean
michel valery mérite vraiment de voir
son trou picouille parce que y'a comme
dans la question sur une plage dans le
doubs dans le doubs c'est dole c'est
dans le jura il n'y a pas beaucoup de
plages à un plus de forêt que le pelage
à s'en plaindre est de la france ya pas
de plagiat pas de mer d'accord ici oui
c'est géographe selo romejko la ccam
météo à la carte l'arrivée rssi alors
allé réveiller
on vous laisse aller dit un troc
couilles vous allez vous dire si c'est
bon je rappelle que c'est vous êtes vous
êtes vous m'avez pas ce que ça peu
salaires piquant tropicaux avec de la
roue illégalement et du fenouil et âmes
des morts de la morceaux de citrouilles
savant à la faille
ah non il ya du hms et devient un truc
typîque équipe i iia du nahd emporté
face à de l'arthrite dans la rigole
c'est de la rouille la rue avec les
pitous sec
merci alors merci au picou que ce blocus
est récente et persistant les années
c'est d'abord vous allez voir ça va nous
faire du bien à l'ailé chéri on passe
maintenant à la question pour les
questions pour un champion
oh merci on passe à maxime ouais
question vous allez jouer pour un flan
les mains dans les mains c'est à dire
vos gobelins flambée sans les bras ok
d'accord sur les mains dans les mains
vrai ou faux maxime l'imitateur gérald
araud a pété un plomb et a défoncé les
stars qui utilisent instagram ça c'est
vrai c'est vrai bien entendu regarder ce
qu'il a dit gérald dahan c'est gérald
dahan bien sûr entre deux imitation
laurent gerra est un humoriste plutôt
discrète s'il officie depuis des
décennies sur rtl avec succès cet
imitateur parmi les plus célèbres de
france ne se sert que très rarement de
sa vraie voix pour dire ce qu'il pense
ce que voilà le confinement lui a lui
aussi semble-t-il taper sur le système
et au premier jour de liberté l'a décidé
de lâcher les chevaux et de dire enfin
ce qu'il a sur le coeur c'est dans une
interview accordée à télé poche que
l'humoriste s'est exprimé son combat à
lui les artistes qui durant plusieurs
semaines ont profité du confinement pour
multiplier les live sur les réseaux
sociaux pour lui c'est une question
d'ego mal placé cette période devrait
concourir à se mettre en retrait à
laisser reposer un peu la patte mais non
il faut absolument s'exhiber déballer sa
vie ses recettes montrer ses abdos pour
lui ces agissements sont purement
mercantiles et autocentrée et ne vont
pas dans le sens de la solidarité
nationale et la sobriété dont les
personnalités devraient faire preuve ils
sont confinés mais on ne les a jamais
autant vu sur les réseaux sociaux comme
s'ils s'étaient investis d'une mission
on se demande bien laquelle il faut dire
qu'avec ses 27 mille abonnés sur
instagram laurent gerra ne semble pas
féru des réseaux sociaux
avec vous le savez mon ami laurent
l'heure actuelle mais dans l'eau mais
c'est vrai jamais nommé et j'aime bien
parce que moi encore laurent girard dit
ce qu'il pense à son compte les accords
avec lui on n'est pas d'accord
non je rigole toujours son avis et c'est
vrai que j'aime sommet et je le range
ira je vous dire c'est un garçon voilà
il apte à cash aident à moi tout ça il
est très douce mais il est voilà ici
c'est pas son truc après voilà qu'on
aime qu'on aimerait me passer à la télé
et alors il posta t oui mais c'est la
leur et ballet face à la télé ça d'avoir
ces poubelles réseau lui passe sur la
télé ils passent sur leurs réseaux
exercer son talent lui c'est pas pour
dire des conneries sur les raisons bahia
bakari koné diaby d'accord 3 puisque
déjà passé le temps de leurs followers
ou alors a fait passer le temps en même
temps problème à force
moi quand je vois des gars qui font par
an des vidéos dans leur douche pour
annoncer une émission lendemain ça me
dégoûte un flash je fais ça je sais pas
mais ça occupe un petit baveux basané
vous avez perdu
non non rien dans les mains merci manu
que le goldman ont bien sûr qu'à une
mémoire de poisson rouge dans les
poubelles sont bien c'est un kobe le
flanc mall cop bad cop bien ceci tu peux
tropicale et qu'elle aimait novelli on
va jouer pour un maître gym direct un
long métrage m gym direct c'est-à-dire
faire une petite leçon de sport à
d'accord moi je vous le dis si sûr du
métro gym vrai ou faux pour remplacer le
public de roland garros
yannick noah propose que chaque joueur
vienne avec un dj pour mettre l'ambiance
ma foi fort ah ouais c'est terminé je
pense que c'est vraiment terminé à 10 h
15 tournoi à huis clos aurait du sens
voilà c'est plan b ça sera ça sera bane
comme le riz la vo
j'avais j'avais une idée c'est que
c'était quand fait que chaque joueur
devait venir et si on dit chez moi sur
le bord du court
tu vois et dès que des tons joueur fait
un point tu peux envoyer bruit ou de la
musique ou des attentions alors on a mal
choisi la personne pour le défi que le
public peut témoigner
kerry a levé les bras et à sa robe qui
s'est levé là le public a été choqué e
là le courrier qui était était pas bien
non mais franchement un public vous avez
été choqué le public va bien mais je
veux de loups à l'abri comme ça on
aurait dû plus bas oui babette un petit
cours de sport mais sans lever les bras
les moulineaux
voilà voilà ça colle aux sports merci
merci khatib envoyé quand elle démarre
albi saint sava le public un petit
verdot
c'est comme un diesel est va merci allez
jean michel maire j'ai une bonne
nouvelle pour vous vous êtes exemptés ce
soir puisque vous avez été le meilleur
élève hier voilà donc j'en ai gardé